Opening up DevTools we very quickly find this error for fail to load resource.
Error name not resolved, yeah, that's how you're supposed to say it.
Clearly this is not a real URL so we see the name not resolved error.
Inside the Network tab we see that this GET request is in red,
indicating that it failed.
Well the other one here for
New York times showed up with a code of 200 indicating that it's a-okay.
If something doesn't look right on your page, going to dev tools and
opening up the network tab is a great place to get started.
We can also see that error handling worked because we failed to
get Wikipedia resources.
This is once again a nice way of letting the users know that, hey,
something didn't quite go right without breaking the entire page.